messieurs bonsoir voici les titres de
l'actualité l'information est tombée
comme un coup de tonnerre hier à 18h30
précise patrick poivre d'arvor l'ex star
du 20 heures accusé de viol par une
écrivaine patrick poivre d'arvor patrick
poivre d'arvor patrick poivre d'arvor
aurait visé par une enquête pour viol
une nouvelle accusation dans la
continuité du mouvement mis tout révélé
par le parisien
l'écrivaine florence porcel 37 ans
aujourd'hui accuse ppda de l'avoir violé
entre 2004 et 2009 alors qu'elle était
étudiante et réaliser un mémoire sur les
ouvrages des personnalités phares du
petit écran dans les colonnes du journal
la présumée victime donne des détails
sordides sur les agissements de l'ex
présentateur et elle dit qu'il va fermer
la porte et puis se jeter sur elle et
l'a violée olb pda l'aurait harcelé
pendant plusieurs années et contrats d
acte forcé la jeune femme a porté
plainte pour viol aggravé
de son côté pour ppda ces accusations
sont fantaisistes il annonce avoir saisi
son avocat maître françois binet alors
êtes vous choqué par les accusations de
viol contre ppda
alors on va revenir sur cette affaire je
voudrais remercier michel polacco d'être
avec nos journalistes êtes un des
meilleurs amis de patrick poivre d'arvor
merci d'être là merci de témoigner ce
soir et merci à marjolaine marjolaine
bui directrice des agences immobilières
maintenant vous aviez participé à greg
le millionnaire vous avez rencontré ppda
ce moment là lorsque vous faisiez ses
émissions vous faisiez greg le
millionnaire marjolaine et les
millionnaires
un dîner est si rude on vous a vu
témoigner sur woodstock people c'est ça
oui c'est un surnom the people et où
c'est vrai que voilà vous avez fait un
témoignage concernant patrick poivre
d'arvor alors déjà acquis et son
accusatrice
si on connaît tous patrick poivre
d'arvor bien entendu on connaît un petit
peu moins florence porcel son
accusatrice florence est principalement
une animatrice et comédienne née en 1983
le mois dernier florence porcel a publié
son premier roman qui accuse ppda sans
le nommer une jeune femme de 19 ans le
pitch du roman une jeune femme de 19 ans
voulait devenir comédienne et va tomber
sous l'emprise de penderie ni un acteur
de 40 ans son aîné cet acteur est aussi
un prédateur sexuel à son décès la
parole se libère et les victimes
témoignent eux voilà florence porcel
aussi à une chaîne youtube
voilà et elle avait été victime
également de la ligue du lol florence
porcel que j'avais eu d'ailleurs je vous
le dit au téléphone à l'époque
et voilà après ces séries voilà qui
était extrêmement sympathique en tout
cas avec qui j'avais changé et ppda
aussi j'ai déjà mal à échanger avec lui
on a déjà bien jouer au tennis ensemble
voilà lors d'un tournoi qui est
extrêmement sympathique série florence
porcel aussi je l'avais eu plusieurs
fois au téléphone au moment de la digue
du lol on s'était bien entendu alors
c'est vrai que cette affaire elle a
secoué tout le monde quels sont les
faits reprochés à ppda donc selon
florence porcel qu'il accuse de viol
patrick poivre d'arvor aurait abusé
d'elle à plusieurs reprises entre 2004
et 2009 j'hibernais oui et notamment une
plainte donc a été déposée pour deux
viols alors 2004 et 2009 2009 c'est une
fellation forcée dans la plainte c'est
explicite on en est à l' enquête
préliminaire qui est classé sensible vu
la personnalité de patrick poivre
d'arvor s'est menée par l'intérieur
alors c'est à dire ça parce que ça s'est
classé sensible c'est à dire que ils
savent très bien les enquêteurs sont des
enquêteurs spécialisés qui savent très
bien que tous leurs actes tout leur
enquête préliminaire va donner lieu à
possible médiatisation ils vont prendre
de précautions et ça
qu' il faut se détacher de la pression
médiatique c'est des enquêteurs
extrêmement spécialisé donc ils vont
essayer de trouver les fesses et la
brigade de répression de la délinquance
à la personne c'est un service très
spécialisé de la pj de paris
d'accord ce qui est très intéressant
c'est l'histoire de 2009 pourquoi parce
que en 2009 à l'époque on avait dix ans
pour porter plainte pour un viol
d'accord mais en 2017 la loi a changé et
quand la loi change dans la période où
vous pouvez porter plainte
la loi a été porté à 20 ans pour la
prescription et donc madame porcel est
tout à fait fondée de porter plainte et
l'effet de 2009 ne sont pas prescrits
ça c'est très important il ya d'autres
affaires où on dit il ya prescription là
il n'y aura pas prescription
donc les gens vont être entendus
d'ailleurs patrick poivre d'arvor a dit
qu'il accepterait d'être entendus et
laon ce moment lui il contre attaque
il se réserve le droit de déposer
plainte pour dénonciation calomnieuse et
diffamation publique
si l'effet aller au bout s'il y avait un
jour un procès s'il était mis en examen
s'il y avait un procès pour viol
il risquerait tout ça est au
conditionnel présomption d'innocence
total il risquait 15 ans de prison
15 ans de prison pour viol alors michel
polacco merci d'être là vous êtes l'un
des meilleurs amis de patrick poivre
d'arvor déjà comment vous avez réagi
hier soir en apprenant les accusations
dont fait l'objet de votre ami hier soir
je suis tombé des nues je connais
patrick depuis 50 ans et une profonde
amitié une de ses amies tirard j'ai
toujours été à ses côtés il a toujours
été à mes côtés lorsqu'on a traversé des
difficultés dans nos vies réciproque
petit à petit avec les années je suis
devenu un membre de la famille j'étais
le parrain de solenn sa fille
je suis très lié à véronique sa femme je
suis très lié à patrick je suis très lié
à ses enfants arnaud dorothée morgan et
à françois le fils que patrick a eu avec
claire chazal et qui l'a élevé comme les
autres enfants et donc c'est ma famille
depuis très longtemps et encore plus
depuis le drame qui nous a touché en
c'est bien sûr avec la disparition de
soleil et je connais bien patrick parce
que l'amitié ça va avec plein de choses
ça va avec des vacances avec des
quantités de moments partagés et dieu
sait si on a tous des qualités et des
défauts et s'il ya une chose que je
connais chez patrick comme étant une
qualité c'est que c'est quelqu'un de
raisonnable de raisonner de doux de
calme c'est le contraire d'une brute
c'est le contraire d'un macho c'est le
contraire d'un personnage qui cherche à
s'imposer c'est donc le contraire
l'homme qu'on décrit de rue dans la
presse depuis hier est-ce que correspond
à celui que vous connaissez pas du tout
cette semaine il écrit dans la presse ce
sont des racontars des ragots des
accusations des choses qui peut être
vont donner lieu une enquête poussée est
très bien très bien
je pense qu'on aurait pu se dispenser de
2 le déshonoré de penne toute sa famille
et ses amis mais s'il faut passer par là
puisque par les temps qui courent on
passe par là pour des tas de gens et
parfois c'est juste et parfois s'est
avéré là je ne le crois pas je suis même
sûr du contraire
s'il faut passer par l'ama passant par
là et on verra ce que dira la justice
moi personnellement je retiens de ce que
j'ai reçu comme information que sur les
dizaines pour ne pas dire les centaines
millions de millions de femmes qui ont
eu l'occasion de croiser patrick sur les
dizaines et autres femmes qui ont à un
moment un autre jouer un rôle dans sa
vie dans la vie de sa famille dans sa
vie professionnelle
jamais aucune
n'a émis le moindre doute sur son
comportement alors justement florence
porcel je vous dis france portel je le
dis je vois là je connais un petit peu
patrick poivre d'arvor
je connais un petit peu florence porcel
et c'est vrai que ces deux personnes
avec qui je m'entendais très bien et qui
je m'entends très bien vrai que j'ai vu
je ne connais pas très très bien mais
voilà et qui s'est très bien passé
notamment florence voilà et patrick la
grande question que tout le monde s'est
posée après les révélations de florence
c est ce qu il ya d'autres victimes
depuis hier il ya beaucoup de
témoignages aussi qu'ils ont été
recensés sur les réseaux sociaux vous
allez voir et vous allez me dire ce que
vous en pensez sa garde alors que
patrick poivre d'arvor se retrouve
aujourd'hui accusé de viol par
l'écrivaine florence porcel et langues
se délient car pour de nombreuses
personnes le comportement déplacé du
journaliste avec les femmes ne serait
pas une découverte
le parisien relate de nombreux
témoignages concordants de la manière
dont l'ancien journaliste de tf1 aurait
à de nombreuses reprises fait pression
sur des femmes pour obtenir leur faveur
c'est le cas par exemple de juliette 44
ans ancienne journaliste reconvertie
dans la communication qui explique la
manière dont le journaliste aurait tenté
d'avoir une relation sexuelle avec elle
alors qu'elle était venue le voir dans
un cadre professionnel
je lui ai donné mon cv il l'a jeté à la
poubelle sans même le regarder je me
suis senti humilié
je me suis levée pour partir et lui se
lever pour essayé de m'embrasser jus est
dit arrêtez patrick ce ne va pas et ça
s'est arrêté là
autre anecdote celle d'une journaliste
d'une radio nationale qui aurait invité
ppda à prendre un verre chez elle alors
qu'il tente de l'embrasser elle refuse
ppda se serait alors adonner aux
plaisirs solitaires sur le canapé de la
journaliste de collègues du journaliste
explique également qu'il était courant
de voir des femmes défiler dans son
bureau la nuit tombée et jeune femme que
les deux assistantes de ppda à tf1
aurait même pris l'habitude de surnommer
le mcdo de patrick un comportement qui
s'il était avéré pourrait peser lourd
dans l' enquête qui est réalisé par la
justice suite à la plainte pour viol
déposée par florence porcel
alors il ya beaucoup de femmes qui
parlent d'un grand séducteur on en
parlait avec valérie bénaïm tout à
l'heure et d'autres qui parlent d'un
plutôt de voilà quelqu'un qui soit qui
était un peu
voilà un prédateur voilà c'est vrai
quels sont pour vous ses rapports avec
les femmes parce que quand vous voyez ça
c'est vrai qu'il est plein de gens qui
ont il ya eu des témoignages sur sur les
réseaux sociaux
valérie vous d'abord j'aimerais avoir
votre ami parce que vous l'avez vous
l'avez moi j'allais rencontrer en l'an
2000 lorsque j'ai préparé ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque le passage à l'an
2000 portait pour pour tf1 c'était un
grand un immense barnum et c'est la
première fois que j'ai croisé la route
de patrick poivre d'arvor se trouve que
je moi je démarrais et j'étais lancer
dans ce dans ce dans ce grand barnum
très impressionné n'oublions pas la méga
star qui était patrick poivre d'arvor 1
parce que c'est là toujours oui mais je
crois qu'on n'imagine pas aujourd'hui à
quel point c'était une vedette
absolument dingue acheter et extrêmement
charismatique et moi je sais que on a
fait une première réunion avec toute la
rédaction on était une cinquantaine et
qu'on sortir de là la réunion un quart
d'heure après dans ma voiture j'ai reçu
un coup de fil de son assistante me
demandant de déjeuner avec patrick
poivre d'arvor parce qu'ils voulaient en
savoir plus sur la nouvelle venue un
séducteur
c'est un immense et du leader mais à
aucun moment je me suis senti en danger
g il m'a invité à déjeuner à l'époque
c'était au crillon donc j'y suis allé
par la suite on art des jeunes et à tf1
même et il était évidemment parce que
c'est un type qui est un excellent
interviewer donc en gros il sait très
bien qu'il a en face de lui donc il sait
comment vous faire plaisir c'est à dire
que moi si moi je sais que j'aime bien
quand on me dit que c'est plutôt
intelligente plutôt que plus jolie
intelligente je suis contente quand on
me dit que je suis intelligente qui en
d2 et donc voilà donc cesser
j'ai eu à faire un très grand séducteur
à aucun moment en revanche je me suis
senti en danger c'est pas pour autant
que je vais remettre en cause la parole
de la victime moi ce qui me gêne
maintenant c'est que aujourd'hui quand
on prend la parole sur ce dossier là
notamment
on a le sentiment soit 2 d'être en
défiance de la présumée victime et si si
si ce qu'elle dit est vrai c'est
absolument terrible soit remettre en
cause la défense du présumé coupable
violeur et si s'il est réellement
innocent c'est terrible aussi donc on
est tous très gêné
c'est vrai que c'est ciani sait que
c'est compliqué marjolaine qui est avec
nous moi je viens de vous vous avez
rencontré patrick poivre d'arvor c'était
ou chez des amis chez un ami d'accord à
neuilly et l'huile organiser enfin des
dîners souvent on était une dizaine
quinzaine pourquoi vous avez voulu
témoigner sur don't stop people en fait
pourquoi vous êtes vous interrogez en
fait aux phocéens non mais parce que
alors moi j'ai été moi je les ai
rencontrés il ya un peu plus de 15 ans
et pareil j'ai eu affaire à quelqu'un de
très séducteur ac très charismatique
très intelligent brillant très humble ce
qui parle un petit peu avec tout le
monde
il a pas de préjugés ni quoi que ce soit
et et on voyait le côté séducteur
clairement mais pas le côté danger parce
que clairement on voyait arriver avec sa
séduction voyait arriver avec ses gros
sabots comme ça à venir vous draguer
tout ça il essaye un comme tout le monde
n'y a pas de voie là mais à aucun moment
pareil comme balles et je me suis senti
en danger ni quoi que ce soit quelques
jours a pris m'avait contacté donc au
téléphone pour m'inviter dans un
week-end au ski et est en fait c'est
pour le trophée des femmes et
je suis demandé mais dans quel contexte
de zohra ben haïm dans quel contexte en
fait le la chaussée que une dizaine
d'hommes et t'inquiète pas il y aura mon
fils et tout ça mais même en fait je
comprenais pas la démarche parce que moi
me retrouver en week-end avec lui au ski
c'est bien voila voila c'était tout sauf
professionnelle ni quoi que ce soit en
plus à l'époque desmarest comme
animatrice télé dont il n'était pas je
voyais pas le contexte il insisté
plusieurs fois moi je fais comprendre
que non c'était pas possible et tout ça
parce que je savais très bien que je me
mettais dans une situation qu'elle est
gênante autant pour moi que pour lui
assure parce que mes attentes n'étaient
pas les mêmes que les siennes voilà donc
peut donc plus de nouvelles bah après je
sais pas si j'ai dû bloquer ou pas non
mais en fait le métier à courchevel
c'était le pdk mains de courchevel y
avait tout le métier de ma composition
puisqu'un et gratuit lui le courant a
brillé alors oui non non ce qui est
évident chez patrick c'est un énorme
séducteur et comme l'a souligné
effectivement valérie elle a raison de
le rappeler c'était une énorme c'est une
énorme star il est extrêmement brillant
il est extrêmement recherchés je peux
vous le confirmer donc c'est vrai que
que tout ce qu'on entend moi ce qui me
choque le plus dans cette histoire je
vous dirai évidemment la présomption
d'innocence on oublie les finales
populaire etc
mais quand je vois notamment le parisien
les commentaires de ses anciens
collègues de tf1 sous anonymat bien sûr
qu'ils commencent à balancer et là c'est
toujours les règlements de compte c'est
toujours un peu pénible c'est moi oui
mais voilà au tour de rester je respecte
à supporter avec beaucoup florence et
voilà après on va voir il y aura une
enquête et on saura voilà ce qui s'est
réellement passé
mais après florent se voit là si elle a
été aussi entendus pour l'insertion mais
c'est vrai que les personnes courent
sous couvert d'anonymat
ancien reporter tf1 et l'autre la
censure prend pas l'ascenseur il va
sauter dessus mais je suis assez
scandaleux de donner caution à ça alors
nathalie ça c'est intéressant parce que
nathalie bon nombre déjà jean pierre
jean prouvé la très choqués et jean
ferrat père dont il a côtoyé pendant des
années dans plus de vingt ans auprès de
lui et franchement il se dit que c'est
pas possible
et moi ce qui me choque quand même c'est
que bon s soit disant qu'elle s'est fait
violer en des mauvais alors mais on va
dire ça veut dire soit disant qu'elle
s'est fait violer la loi ni pardon et
jeudi et florence pour ça que j'ai eus
simulation à jimi hendrix et pas ne
s'est pas une folle en france pour cette
norme g - ce qui est ce qui me choque
quand même viser quelqu'un de bien voilà
ouais non mais ce qui me choque après
cinq ans après elle
téléphone pour demander à l'interview
alors ça veut rien que ça je sais pas
mais sans rien dire ça si on reste en
aide si on a été violée moi j'aurais
peur de voir mon violeur en face de moi
et je pense que ppda n'aurait pas
accepté de la voir s'il avait quelque
chose
non on peut voir les torsions gens là
dessus sur jeu
sur le fond on ne sait rien présomption
d'innocence mais elle ce qu'elle dit est
ce qu'elle avait écrit dans son roman à
tiroirs la dea qui est sorti en janvier
c'est qu'il y a une emprise une
manipulation qui fait qu'elle est sous
influence donc je ne dis pas je prends
pas du tout partie mais sa thèse à elle
sait qu'il ya cette emprise et ce soir
on ne reprend pas partie des arguments
semaine passée c'est que elle elle dit
elle qu'il y as en prise et qu'elle
était sous influence
et quand une femme est sous influence et
bien mais oui nathalie c'est ce qu'elle
dit et quand une femme est sous
influence
eh bien elle subit voilà ce qu'elle dit
alors est-ce que vous la connaissiez
michel pas du tout pas du tout je ne
savais même pas qu'elle existait
d'accord parce que ces cinq ans quand
même ils ont ils ont cohabité sans fin
non ils ont jamais cohabité ans mais
c'est énorme il se sait tous me soit
dans l'histoire de la vie de patrick
elle est venue le voir plusieurs fois
tf1 elle est venue en 2009 le voir une
fois à côté d'ici chea prime
d'accord elle était venue pour le
féliciter et lui dire l'amour qu'elle
portait à son roman sur la mort de
domjean et de cet accord
bon j'ai compris que chaque fois elle
satisfait particulièrement de manière à
plaire même ça ça veut rien dire on ne
fait pas parce qu'il fallait pas voir là
stups la plus courte et bien sûr mais ça
n'a pas eu d'effets les voilà exactement
une femme a droit d'être belle et de
voilà le saviez qu'un pur bah oui mais
je dis encore une fois être patrick
l'avait même pas particulièrement été
bon il l'invité je crois de trois fois
dans son émission l'île elle même elle a
même obtenu une fois le prix de la
nouvelle vol de nuit de son émission vol
de nuit
voilà mais bon c'était elle lui a écrit
pas mal et il lui a toujours répondu
comme il répond d'ailleurs à tous les
gens qui lui envoie des vivres à tous
les gens qui lui écrivent ils
il répond c'est quelqu'un qui aime son
public voilà mes branchement elles
étaient complètement inconnus et voyez
moi il répond ce truc là j'aurais jamais
su qu'elle avait sorti un bouquin au
début du mois de janvier
je pense que d'ailleurs pour elles c'est
sans doute une année pour faire un bruit
mais bon ça on peut pas parler de ça
mais je vous dis flo florence elle fait
son livre on l'a on ait parlé d'elle
aussi au moment d'une autre affaire qui
ont appelé de la fédé allié la ligue du
lol qu'il avait fait énormément souffrir
aussi à florence donc voilà elle est là
elle a quand même eu des moments
difficiles oui benjamin attend derrière
par action sur vous il n'y a pas de
censure vous nos coqs nicolas pernikoff
un cem et moi j'ai rencontré patrick
poivre d'arvor je suis pas spécialement
je connais pas très bien la seule chose
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'il ya
toujours eu ces rumeurs autour de
patrick poivre d'arvor
ça date d'il ya 20 ou 30 ans mais des
rôles de séducteur non il ya eu descendu
avec des rumeurs beaucoup plus salaces
que ça est entre autres on parlait
souvent même à tf1 il se passait des
choses je pense juste jeunes à risque
une mise en commun pourrait pas non mais
c'est pas ça mais elle est beaucoup de
choses qui ont été dits je ne peux pas
croire une minute qu'une maison comme
tf1 laisserait se faire ce qui se passe
ou ce qui se dit aujourd'hui dans la
presse donc un moment donné il ya la
présomption d'innocence ya juste un truc
c'est que ces rumeurs il ya toujours eu
des rumeurs autour de 8 c'est pourquoi
parce que c'est l'icône du 20 heures
c'est une star patrick poivre d'arvor a
jamais on en a pas et cette semaine je
pense que c'est le résumé de la
situation actuelle le fait qu'il soit
ppda que vous dites ce soit un homme
brillant intelligent ne peut pas dire
qu'il pourrait pas être un monstre on
est d'accord et on a déjà vu
précédemment
mais maintenant il est extrêmement
connue c'est vrai on va pas se mentir on
peut faire les langues de bois et me
cyril tout le monde dans le métier avait
dansé dire que patrick était plutôt un
séducteur un séducteur un homme à femmes
séducteur et prédateurs ces deux jeux
différents
comme on l'a dit
haïr ou avant-hier c'est vrai que
maintenant et encore une fois libéré la
parole c'est essentiel pouvoir dire les
choses c'est essentiel mais attention
c'est faut pas non plus que le fait
d'être célèbre
le fait d'avoir une vie agitée une
sentimentalement amoureusement mêmes
deviennent vos face de vous
systématiquement un violeur un prédateur
est un mec dangereux et là je vous le
dis encore une fois l'enquète elle
commence alors on ne sait pas ce qui va
se passer moi avec martine ni pour
patrick ni pour la présumée à florence
mais pour florence mais attention c'est
je vous aime et pourtant elle a le droit
de passage public donc comme ça pas
acceptable en droit d'en parler cela on
va sur le riz donc quand on est une
révélation par jour quasiment sur une
personne connue ou célèbres qui rue un
comportement déplacé dangereux que je
vous le dis il faut faire attention
encore une fois un pour l'instant c'est
le début de l' enquête
moi je dis c'est possible encore une
fois le vxo ppda ne veut pas dire que je
pas un monstre mais encore faut-il de
prouver donc on en est on n'en sait rien
là il est dans quel état patrick
aujourd'hui bail est très très touché et
doigt les dangers que il dort dans son
environnement très proches sa famille ce
soir ces enfants sont mais complètement
effondrée parce que eux comme moi mais
mieux encore que moi le connaissent
parfaitement et si on peut lui reprocher
effectivement des incas valeur parce que
il a beaucoup plu aux femmes que les
femmes mûres ou beaucoup justin bien
avant que ça il ya une rumeur qui dit
qu'il y avait des femmes quatre tours
des dégâts fait valérie bénaïm breaking
rumeur qui dit qu à vis à vis et pas
besoin de ça moi j'ai jamais vu un gamin
qui vivait en revanche oui mais juste
c'est quoi la rumeur la rumeur sur
patrick on va pas se mentir tout le
monde tout le monde savait dans pareil
qu'il était qu'il aimait bien les femmes
ne seraient pas de lui un criminel un
violeur est pour l'instant encore une
fois et c'est ce que je voulais en
aviser aussi femmes n'ont baissé
non mais qu'est-ce que vous avez rectal
heures un homme courtisé dans la loterie
des médias
enterrement voilà je finissais vous
finirez lundi on va reparler merci oui
est-ce que vous avez un dernier mot à
dire un dernier mot jeu je trouve qu'il
est dommage qu'on puisse faire d'abord
le procès médiatique avant que
l'instruction la vraie est eu lieu je
sais je pense qu'il y a des tas
d'éléments qui permettent d'ores et déjà
d'avoir des doutes sur cette affaire
quand jeudi des doutes ses terres penser
qu'elle n'a pas eu lieu
sauf que c'est pas possible de les
utiliser et donc patrick va être
maltraité sa famille maltraités
déshonoré pendant des semaines peut-être
des mois en attendant que la justice
puisse faire son travail et je trouve
que une nouvelle fois c'est déplorable